One of the most useful abstractions provided
by high-level languages is the notion of a
procedure or subroutine, which is a sequence
of instructions that perform a specific task.
A procedure has a single named entry point,
which can be used to refer to the procedure
in other parts of the program.
In the example here, this code is defining
the GCD procedure, which is declared to return
an integer value.
Procedures have zero or more formal parameters,
which are the names the code inside the procedure
will use to refer the values supplied when
the procedure is invoked by a "procedure call".
A procedure call is an expression that has
the name of the procedure followed by parenthesized
list of values called "arguments" that will
be matched up with the formal parameters.
For example, the value of the first argument
will become the value of the first formal
parameter while the procedure is executing.
The body of the procedure may define additional
variables, called "local variables", since
they can only be accessed by statements in
the procedure body.
Conceptually, the storage for local variables
only exists while the procedure is executing.
They are allocated when the procedure is invoked
and deallocated when the procedure returns.
The procedure may return a value that's the
result of the procedure's computation.
It's legal to have procedures that do not
return a value, in which case the procedures
would only be executed for their "side effects",
e.g., changes they make to shared data.
Here we see another procedure, COPRIMES, that
invokes the GCD procedure to compute the greatest
common divisor of two numbers.
To use GCD, the programmer of COPRIMES only
needed to know the input/output behavior of
GCD, i.e., the number and types of the arguments
and what type of value is returned as a result.
The procedural abstraction has hidden the
implementation of GCD, while still making
its functionality available as a "black box".
This is a very powerful idea: encapsulating
a complex computation so that it can be used
by others.
Every high-level language comes with a collection
of pre-built procedures, called "libraries",
which can be used to perform arithmetic functions
(e.g., square root or cosine),
manipulate collections of data (e.g., lists
or dictionaries), read data from files, and
so on - the list is nearly endless!
Much of the expressive power and ease-of-use
provided by high-level languages comes from
their libraries of "black boxes".
The procedural abstraction is at the heart
of object-oriented languages, which encapsulate
data and procedures as black boxes called
objects that support specific operations on
their internal data.
For example, a LIST object has procedures
(called "methods" in this context) for indexing
into the list to read or change a value, adding
new elements to the list, inquiring about
the length of the list, and so on.
The internal representation of the data and
the algorithms used to implement the methods
are hidden by the object abstraction.
Indeed, there may be several different LIST
implementations to choose from depending on
which operations you need to be particularly
efficient.
Okay, enough about the virtues of the procedural
abstraction!
Let's turn our attention to how to implement
procedures using the Beta ISA.
A possible implementation is to "inline" the
procedure, where we replace the procedure
call with a copy of the statements in the
procedure's body, substituting argument values
for references to the formal parameters.
In this approach we're treating procedures
very much like UASM macros, i.e., a simple
notational shorthand for making a copy of
the procedure's body.
Are there any problems with this approach?
One obvious issue is the potential increase
in the code size.
For example, if we had a lengthy procedure
that was called many times, the final expanded
code would be huge!
Enough so that inlining isn't a practical
solution except in the case of short procedures
where optimizing compilers do sometimes decide
to inline the code.
A bigger difficulty is apparent when we consider
a recursive procedure where there's a nested
call to the procedure itself.
During execution the recursion will terminate
for some values of the arguments and the recursive
procedure will eventually return answer.
But at compile time, the inlining process
would not terminate and so the inlining scheme
fails if the language allows recursion.
The second option is to "link" to the procedure.
In this approach there is a single copy of
the procedure code which we arrange to be
run for each procedure call - all the procedure
calls are said to link to the procedure code.
Here the body of the procedure is translated
once into Beta instructions and the first
instruction is identified as the procedure's
entry point.
The procedure call is compiled into a set
of instructions that evaluate the argument
expressions and save the values in an agreed-upon
location.
Then we'll use a BR instruction to transfer
control to the entry point of the procedure.
Recall that the BR instruction not only changes
the PC but saves the address of the instruction
following the branch in a specified register.
This saved address is the "return address"
where we want execution to resume when procedure
execution is complete.
After branching to the entry point, the procedure
code runs, stores the result in an agreed-upon
location and then resumes execution of the
calling program by jumping to the supplied
return address.
To complete this implementation plan we need
a "calling convention" that specifies where
to store the argument values during procedure
calls and where the procedure should store
the return value.
It's tempting to simply allocate specific
memory locations for the job.
How about using registers?
We could pass the argument value in registers
starting, say, with R1.
The return address could be stored in another
register, say R28.
As we can see, with this convention the BR
and JMP instructions are just what we need
to implement procedure call and return.
It's usual to call the register holding the
return address the "linkage pointer".
And finally the procedure can use, say, R0
to hold the return value.
Let's see how this would work when executing
the procedure call fact(3).
As shown on the right, fact(3) requires a
recursive call to compute fact(2), and so
on.
Our goal is to have a uniform calling convention
where all procedure calls and procedure bodies
use the same convention for storing arguments,
return addresses and return values.
In particular, we'll use the same convention
when compiling the recursive call fact(n-1)
as we did for the initial call to fact(3).
Okay.
In the code shown on the right we've used
our proposed convention when compiling the
Beta code for fact().
Let's take a quick tour.
To compile the initial call fact(3) the compiler
generated a CMOVE instruction to put the argument
value in R1 and then a BR instruction to transfer
control to fact's entry point while remembering
the return address in R28.
The first statement in the body of fact tests
the value of the argument using CMPLEC and
BT instructions.
When n is greater than 0, the code performs
a recursive call to fact, saving the value
of the recursive argument n-1 in R1 as our
convention requires.
Note that we had to first save the value of
the original argument n because we'll need
it for the multiplication after the recursive
call returns its value in R0.
If n is not greater than 0, the value 1 is
placed in R0.
Then the two possible execution paths merge,
each having generated the appropriate return
value in R0, and finally there's a JMP to
return control to the caller.
The JMP instruction knows to find the return
address in R28, just where the BR put it as
part of the original procedure call.
Some of you may have noticed that there are
some difficulties with this particular implementation.
The code is correct in the sense that it faithfully
implements procedure call and return using
our proposed convention.
The problem is that during recursive calls
we'll be overwriting register values we need
later.
For example, note that following our calling
convention, the recursive call also uses R28
to store the return address.
When executed, the code for the original call
stored the address of the HALT instruction
in R28.
Inside the procedure, the recursive call will
store the address of the MUL instruction in
R28.
Unfortunately that overwrites the original
return address.
Even the attempt to save the value of the
argument N in R2 is doomed to fail since during
the execution of the recursive call R2 will
be overwritten.
The crux of the problem is that each recursive
call needs to remember the value of its argument
and return address, i.e., we need two storage
locations for each active call to fact().
And while executing fact(3), when we finally
get to calling fact(0) there are four nested
active calls, so we'll need 4*2 = 8 storage
locations.
In fact, the amount of storage needed varies
with the depth of the recursion.
Obviously we can't use just two registers
(R2 and R28) to hold all the values we need
to save.
One fix is to disallow recursion!
And, in fact, some of the early programming
languages such as FORTRAN did just that.
But let's see if we can solve the problem
another way.